hearings continue today for the
council's draft long-term plan and why
mercury district councillors say they
are pleased with the amount and quality
of feedback they're receiving from the
community we've got 60 submissions that
we're listening to verbally over the
next few days
out of over 800 that have been but and
so it's really good to hear from people
firsthand of what they're thinking and
to be able to ask some questions around
their process the very book submissions
are very important as we see face to
face with the people that want to come
along to counsel and hear their issues
that they wish us to listen to and that
is so important for us to hear this side
of the story and it helps us make our
decision a way that we need to verbal
submissions will be completed today
councilors will then consider all the
feedback from the consultation process
and go into deliberations from May 29th
to the 31st formal adoption of the LTP
is expected to take place at a council
meeting on the 19th of June and we'll
let you know if the key decisions made
as they take place